welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn we'll coast and our guest is
Pierrot bellow Britto an associate
research scientist at the Yale Child
Study Center
professor Brito is known nationally for
her work on young children's literacy
and social and identity development of
Muslim Arab children as well as
internationally for her scientific
commitment to cross-cultural issues
evidence-based national policy
development and early learning standards
for young children her primary expertise
is in the role of socio-cultural factors
in child development and early childhood
policies and programs in the developing
world today we'll talk with her about
early childhood development and policy
in a global context
welcome professor Brito thank you for
having me you've recently written a
paper on child development focusing
particularly on child rights and policy
implications please give us an overview
I'd love to
the goal of this paper really is to
bring the evidence on context the most
intimate contexts and situations in
which young children grow and develop in
the developing world and then use a
rights-based perspective or a
rights-based lens to understand that
context so we can inform national level
policies to improve these conditions
improve these circumstances and so this
is sort of this culminates a series of
papers that was put together by a
collaborative study team that consists
of academic partners non-academic
partners and I CHT we had UNICEF we had
a study team that came together to very
critically examine these home
environment contexts who look at child
rearing practices to look at caregiving
to look at the degree to which children
are exposed to violence abuse neglect
and then with a very nuanced and
detailed understanding of that which we
know is one of the most important
influences on a growing child and then
take a rights-based perspective and see
what can we do to really enhance the
situation of children rights based tools
like the Human Rights Convention we have
in the Convention on the Rights of the
Child which is a very powerful tool and
I'm not sure if you know Marilyn it's
the most widely signed and ratified
human rights treaty I did not know that
so every country other than Somalia and
the United States interesting I've
signed and ratified it so it's a very
powerful tool it's universally endorsed
that means as a world community will
recognize the importance of children and
we understand and we believe in those
principles but it's not used that
frequently to really mobilize policy
it's not used that frequently to move
issues forward so we wanted to take the
data and use a rights-based length to
try and speak with countries to see how
they could improve conditions for
children okay I have to ask why do you
think the United States is not signed to
this no I don't think there's a problem
in this country or I'm not it seems
remarkable to me yes and you are not the
only person to sort of be astounded
standard by by this fact there are
multiple reasons there are multiple
reasons why the United States has not
signed it the one that's probably the
clearest to explain is the fact that the
US Constitution is supreme and and our
Constitution doesn't allow other
international laws to superimpose its
articles do restrictions upon us and
therefore for that reason the United
States has chosen not to be a signatory
on the convention but then there are
multiple other reasons which we could go
into or say for a later discussion well
let's talk a little bit about the
methodology that
you used for the paper I know you used a
particular survey that is very important
and innovative and unique so let's talk
about that a little bit yes
it's very interesting so let me before
before studying about the methodology
give you another startling fact okay
90% of the world's children live in the
majority world of the developing world
it's 10% that live in the Western world
the flip side of it is 90% of the
literature or the information the
knowledge base the developmental science
comes from this 10% of children so what
do we know and say today is really based
on 10% of the world's children the 600
million who I live in everywhere in the
world we know very little about so
having said that what we really need to
do is understand what is going on in the
lives of these children
what's going on with breastfeeding
what's going on with nutrition what's
going on when mothers are talking to
children we have to have cogent evidence
around this and the mix survey the multi
indicate a cluster survey is really what
we used it's one of the largest
household surveys globally and it came
out of a declaration which was called
the world fit for children declaration
and it's sponsored by UNICEF it's
implemented around the world and the
beauty of this is in the most recent so
it's been going through multiple waves
the most recent wave was conducting 2005
they included a lot of questions about
this immediate and most influential
context for children under five we were
able to use that data and I think the
very unique aspect of our paper was to
take the principles of children's rights
to survive develop be protected and
participate and take that lens and look
at the data and say and see what is
going on are we really up holding
children's rights mm-hmm and that's sort
of what we were able to bring to this
paper okay the survey seems enormous to
me I mean how many countries were polled
are taken into consideration or
took part in the survey and how actually
was it administered so the survey itself
is grant and huge as you see and it's
and it's um it's a very very complicated
it's so two very briefly to be
completely simple about it is countries
agree with UNICEF to administer and
implement the survey the sampling for
which is multi-layered
in such that fairly representative
households are sampled in a country
there are multiple modules that look at
health nutrition education economic
status and in countries can elect which
modules a questions they select from
that and then through a national process
of vetting the data and analysis
countries released reports on how well
they're doing by their children our
study was one one Micro sample of it was
28 countries with a particular emphasis
on early childhood the UNICEF website
has a lot of information on the mix
survey on the methodology and the
details of this which in some ways is is
fascinating because we are really
getting a nuanced look at children
finally then just sort of broad
statistics of GDPs and you know
mortality indices and education so what
were some of your findings based on the
research the findings were so we had a
sample of 28 countries that we looked at
and in this study and we sort of had
them for them for the ease of
categorization we should have looked at
high human development index middle
human development Nixon low Human
Development Index countries and I think
what was very interesting was that so on
average we found for example only
one-fourth of the mother said they had
breastfed their children the previous
day children younger than six months of
age due to lack of food or they
purchased so when child is younger than
six months of age the w-h-o standards
are exclusive breastfeeding another
remarkable statistic was only one-third
of the mothers had
told read a story to a child told a
story to a child in the past week now I
do want to put in a caveat here is that
the means or the average belies the huge
distribution and range so the range in
the answers we got across the countries
was enormous so in some ways you can't
just peg it to the mean but that being
said the uppermost range of many of the
responses we got we're still lower than
what is required for sort of what would
should be in place for optimal
development what we know children need
what we know is a nurturing and a
stimulating environment so we know there
is a lot to be done we know that if
we're not upholding the basic
development rights of children there is
a lot we should be doing and that was
very helpful information that we got
very hard information we got from these
surveys and we will be able to marry it
with a rights perspective ok and and
what are some of the recommendations in
terms of the evidence that you found in
and what countries can be doing so then
we took the recommend we took the data
and and we started looking at
implications of it for how could you
let's say enhance breastfeeding
exclusive breastfeeding practices what
does the literature tell us in terms of
group counseling in terms of serviceable
availability we looked at the data and
said how could we encourage parents
maybe to spend more time engaging with
their children and what are some
successful program models out there they
have done this and so we sort of tried
we can't toward the recommendations to
moving in in that direction I know
you've spent a lot of time and Laos and
I'd like to talk a little bit about that
experience your work there and the
scientific based evidence that you came
up with and how that can inform policy
yeah I I was very fortunate to work and
now it's a beautiful country it's just
just beautiful its Southeast Asia it's
unfortunately though
a landlocked country it sort of ranks
very low in economic development its
mired by by you know disturbing
statistics with respect to infant
mortality access to health care access
to education pilot a country with a lot
of promise and it's a country that's
really interested in moving out of these
ranks and so they have elected to invest
in human capital mm-hmm really build a
citizenry and as scientific evidence we
know building human capital starts in
the earliest years neurobiological data
tells us about brain development
economic data tells us about the return
on investment in early programming so we
have multiple bodies of evidence of
knowledge of scientific inquiry they
tell us building human capital starts in
the early years so Laos has really
decided to move along in that direction
and our role and I'm part of the
university was really to work as a
evidence-based partner in this process
the the country led the process it was a
national development it was led by the
key ministries health education social
welfare justice who really are pushing
programs for children it was very much
in response to what are the national
needs and priorities for young children
and the goal was to build a sustainable
policy and this is a huge part of what
we bring to the table as part of sort of
sustainability is the evidence that we
know is going to sustain the policy
oftentimes that people you know you
often hear this rhetoric oh they have
great policies but an implementation it
falls apart falls apart because there is
incapacity sustainability there isn't
financial sustainability there isn't
social sustainability the community
doesn't own it so what we bring to this
process is how do you build that
sustainability on the different pieces
of evidence so if the governance model
of the policy isn't strong when it goes
from national to district to provincial
it's going to fall apart so what is the
evidence to build sustainability if we
don't have enough resources Alec
- this policy and distributed correctly
to the programs it's not going to be
financially sustainable viable we bring
evidence in terms of knowing how
financing policies work so that's sort
of what we bring to the dialogue and
then there is a great participation that
occurs with all the key stakeholders and
we've taken a lot of yale students to
this process as you know and the other
piece of this work that i want to talk
about is it's been a phenomenal training
experience for yale students and i'm
sure and i often sort of use this
example you know i often say you cannot
learn to be a physician by just studying
anatomy textbooks you have to be
interacting with patients who have to be
res you have to do a residency you'll
have to do the training the same thing
with policy you cannot learn policy in a
classroom if you've got to be in the
policy arena you've got to be
interacting with policy makers you've
got to understand how ideology
institutional capacity information how
do all of this into play when you are
trying to get something strong on the
table to move forward an agenda so we
often take a group of students with me
and i've been very fortunate the
university's been very supportive of
this and help fund the students travel
and they get to participate in these
policy deliberations interact with
policymakers and learn the process learn
how do you engage in an evidence-based
conversation such that you're going to
get to the goals the objectives the
targets you want and i understand in
your work in laos that you actually did
help create policy that has been
implemented in that so can you tell us
give us a few examples of some of the
things that have been implemented there
yes so so what has been very interesting
in in lewis's when when we first started
working there it was something very
simple like there wasn't even a mapping
of the different services that exist for
children and getting a sense of where to
move forward so just a basic situational
of what's going on what are the services
who are the key stakeholders involved
what are the indicators for children in
what dimensions are programs lacking
some degree of quality and substance was
nothing so what has been very useful so
that was a basic piece of it the second
part of this that was very useful was it
was sort of a historical precedent was
said in the country that they had so
many key ministries come together at the
same table to discuss an area of common
interest so typically you know the
health sector works individually and
education sector works individually this
was a policy that brought together
government non-government development
partners but not just at a central level
there was also sort of a a vertical
level of contribution with provincial
partners their district level partners
there so in terms of the process this
was a very unique conversation that had
occurred and it was sort of remarked on
and used as a model for other policies
that are being developed the next piece
of this that has actually been very
fabulous is the country now is
developing a very detailed plan of
action so the policies are the broad
statement of where the country wants to
go in terms of improving children's
lives in terms of getting to healthy
citizenry mmm-hmm the country now has
decided that they want a detailed plan
that breaks it up here by your step by
step with accountabilities withdrawals
responsibilities with funds being
allocated to expansion of kindergarten
programs expansion of community-based
programs scaling up of immunization
program so we're seeing many different
directions in which now there are
detailed steps being outlined to move
this forward it's wonderful in terms
let's go back to the global policy I'm
very curious to know so there's a global
policy but there's so many countries at
in the developing world of at different
levels of development how does that work
to have a global policy and then
implement it at the national level
so there isn't one I guess I should
start by saying that isn't one global
policy okay and with respect to young
children really who we're talking about
is children prenatally to about eight
years of age and we're not just talking
about the growing child we're talking
about the context around the child the
services that the child receives the the
programs and provisions that enhance the
development of human potential so in
order to achieve that there isn't one
global policy this sort of two big
drivers they're the conventions the
human rights convention like the
convention and the rights of child the
ILO conventions on prevention against
child labor those conventions and then
there are the declarations the
declarations are the MDGs are the most
well known the Millennium Development
Goals okay of the education for all
goals eye health for all goals these
declaration so typically countries
contour their national policies
oftentimes to fit these international
targets okay so we're only childhood
fits in is that it gets piecemeal
attention you know if there is a
declaration and a goal around it like
the big goal is universal primary
education the MDGs talk about it the
education for all goal talked about so
you see a huge push across the board
national level country national level
policies to promote universal enrollment
in primary school in fact on average a
Ministry of Education spends 50 percent
of its budget on primary education so
you see this sort of an attention to
early childhood there isn't there isn't
sort of a in across-the-board cohesive
attention and this is something that I
think a lot of us are thinking about
seriously and considering and in fact
I'm just back from a meeting we had in
Bellagio at the Rockefeller Foundation
Center that was proposed by myself and
some of my colleagues to look at the
state of evidence on early childhood
with respect to can we really come up
with a framework to inform these
International Drivers international
drivers at Porsche national policies in
a way that children get this cohesive
attention so we're not sort of get
these children with a head and neck and
shoulders you know we're really getting
the full charge and this was a very
interesting meeting we had global
scholars from 24 countries really
talking about the state-of-the-art
evidence and what can we put together to
talk to these big declarations to see if
there's a greater inclusion and what
came out of the meeting what came out of
the meeting was a very interesting
structure of how we should be thinking
about the evidence from the different
sectors that address kids health
education legal systems justice but also
looking at the evidence from faith-based
organizations NGOs private sector and
how can we put these together to really
understand what is the strongest
provisions for children and how are we
in some ways maybe not attentive to a
fullest potential if we cut up the work
in this multiple ways so we have a we
have a ways to go but this group sort of
came together and thinking together this
framework in over the next couple of
months actually by next year we should
have a pretty authoritative volume out
on this one you can use for a high-level
launch and so what do you think is the
most important thing that needs to
happen to help child rights and policy
that's there multiple parts to this
answer I think just because early
childhood development is very complex in
that it really brings together multiple
sectors and agencies who are working
towards children's development and sort
of the economic development of a country
so for the most I would sort of say
they're pieces to this that come
together in an interesting tapestry but
then there isn't sort of a linear
arrangement around it in in my
experience and in sort of working with
now of 40 odd countries around the world
with governments national governments on
improving conditions for young children
one piece I I find that is quite
remarkable is oftentimes parents or key
caregivers in the
we are not aware of the importance of
these early years and that learning does
begin at birth and that everything we do
with young children enhances their
capacity and their ability and their
potential I mean there is a universal
recognition of wanting your children to
be healthy to be happy I mean I've done
focus groups and remote at with remote
populations in Laos I've done folks
trips and families and sort of very
educated in Singapore and they'll all
you ask them what do you want for your
children and they all say we want
healthy children we want to be happy to
be successful but once you start going
back and saying how do you think this
happens and what could you do that's
when we notice there is a knowledge gap
and that's really what we need to work
on I think if somehow there was ways
there and there are ways to really get
the word out about the importance of the
early years about immunization about
health about breastfeeding families will
start demanding that and once families
communities public will build to demand
from the government and we see what
demand can do recently we're seeing a
lot of yes once a population starts
demanding what they need we will see
service provision change we will see
policies responsive to that but
education really is the first step is
the first step and there is a very key
link between particularly maternal
education maternal understanding and
child well-being another big piece to
this is the capacity to deliver programs
and deliver these services in most
countries the problem with scaling up is
they're not sufficient trained
individuals to actually take it forward
right and so the quality of the work and
the effectiveness of the program starts
dropping and if we had systems to
actually enhance capacity to build
training models we could reach a large
number of population families children
we are not reaching now and the the
advantage to all of this is we have
technology no longer are we bound into
classrooms
walls have exploded have expanded and
through technology there are multiple
ways we can really build build capacity
and finally I think we need stronger
arguments that really link this
investment in the early years and
economic development of countries we
have it we have the data that shows the
return on investing in early programs
gives you a high return and a higher
reward what is missing is that for the
most part governments are not going to
wait 20 years for that to mature you
know you want more immediate goals you
want an immediate return you want a
short-term return that needs to be
strengthened for there to be upgraded
buying an investment and interest in
this work and I think if all these start
coming together we are going to see the
landscape change because right now the
very sad story is I would say one third
of young children under five years of
age is not achieving their full
potential and we start multiplying that
into a loss of human potential world
very sad well you're doing wonderful
work thank you so much for being here
today ensuring some of your research
thank you
for more information about Professor
Britto and her work please visit our
website at Yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you